the story that i have for you today is
one that took place decades ago when i
was
14 years old and some of it happened
while i was finishing up my
freshman year of high school and then
the rest is in the summer in between
freshman and sophomore
years
i would turn 15 later on that summer uh
you know in in late august
so most of this is happening when i'm
you know 14 years old and
the story goes back there's a lot of
different moving parts to it so it goes
back a little bit before i actually
got mono in order to understand how this
ended up happening and mono is
mononucleosis it's it's a
viral disease that you can get it's
often called the kissing disease and i
think that's actually how i ended up
getting it but you can get it in other
ways as well and then it's one of these
things that stays in your
system
and you know it can it can lead to
problems later on
i don't think it has for me
so we got to back this up to spring
break of my
freshman year so we'd be talking about
early
1985 we're actually not really that
early we're talking about april right
because spring break coincided more or
less with the
easter holiday and so
my mom and sister and my mom's boyfriend
fran
we went down to panama city beach
florida and we like rented a bungalow
and you know we go out to the beach each
day
and my mom was in an organization called
parents without partners and i think by
that time she was also in the vagabond
ski club and these were organizations
that were for
divorcees or widows and widowers people
who had kids and wanted to get together
with other people who had kids i guess
you know in part to for support and
commiseration but also because then the
kids could go do stuff and then the
adults could enjoy themselves and they
could all relate to each other
so we went down with several other
families on this trip and some of them i
already knew from parents without
partners
and then there was another family that
was was new to me
and they i was 14 years old they had a
17 year old senior girl who and they
lived in in milwaukee
who was you know quite attractive and
and uh uh found me
interesting and i found her interesting
i was uh very much into heavy metal at
the time so i was constantly walking
around with this boombox i was like
maybe you know i was as tall as i am
and was starting to grow my hair long
and i was probably maybe 145 pounds i
think i'd gained a little bit of weight
because of weightlifting and stuff like
that anyway this this
girl lori um she was you know hitting on
me and you know we flirted back and
forth and we'd go and take
walks and go out you know and swim at
night and stuff like that so we're
starting to get closer and of course you
know it's kind of an
in in some ways it's like a rock and
roll fantasy right
so long story short towards the end of
the uh the week that we were spending
down there
had my first kiss
lost my virginity uh all like out on the
beach at night uh with you know rat and
motley crew playing on my boombox and
the ocean and et cetera et cetera right
so it was kind of a uh
you know an interesting
set of experiences and then i saw her
two more times after that you know we go
back
and i'm not sure what exactly was going
on but we lived out in the sticks in in
the hills of delafield between wales and
delafield wisconsin and as i said she
lived in milwaukee so she
you know she'd like call me up and stuff
like that
and she came out with her mom
and maybe her her sister who was about
my sister's age
and uh you know we
took a walk made out all that sort of
stuff um got interrupted by my my
grandpa who was kind of nosy and then
she went on her her way and then she'd
like call me up and she wanted me to go
on dates with her and my mom was not big
on this idea but eventually uh relented
and so
i was at you know my mom's boyfriend
fran's place in in elm grove
and was kind of halfway in between so
lori came out picked me up we
actually went to a bar in milwaukee
where we were shooting pool and you know
drinking slogan fizzes and other stuff
like that
um
when i was only 14 she was 17 so
obviously you know underage drinking and
stuff like that and then you know we
drove around a bit made out at her car
some more
and um you know that that was more or
less that
and
then
meanwhile at the same time you know my
freshman year i well actually all three
of my my first three years i ran track
and i would run the
400 meter called the 440 right the 440
yards and i would run that race and then
i would also run the mile relay which is
four guys um
running with a baton
each of them doing a quarter mile or at
a 440 and then you hand off the baton so
i was stuck doing that race twice every
trackmate and i didn't like it much
the 440 you take off at a sprint and you
know by the time that you hit about the
halfway point lactic acid starting to
build up in your body and you get to the
three-quarter point you hit what's
called the bear where it feels like you
know your muscles are clenching and
maybe a bear is tearing your scratching
you down your back or something like
that and then you just gotta like push
it out so i had to do that twice every
every track meet
and you know i tried to do other things
but my coach was like no you're a 440
runner keep
stay in your lane so to speak
so
i'm sick right i'm starting to get sick
and it's the very last track meet of the
year
in
late may
a beautiful day you know nice and warm
and stuff like that i'm not feeling
great you know so i do my 440 i don't i
don't think i had a particularly good
time but you know when you're sick
you're sick and then i had to do the
mile relay and the mile relay is the
last event of the track meets at least
at the level that i was at
so i do my mile relay and you know after
i i finish
handing the baton off i like you know
run off and like grab a fence because
i'm just about passing out
and coughing and stuff like that and
my mom and fran come by and they're like
oh you don't look good and i'm like yeah
i don't feel good you know and so i i go
home and they got me like some i don't
know some
of the popsicles that we used to have
these push-up popsicles and and i'm you
know laying in bed and sweating bullets
and um you know back then we didn't have
air conditioning there was only one
family on our entire street that had air
conditioning and it's already getting
kind of warm and you know i'm i'm
feeling really really rough and so the
next day my mom is like we're going to
the doctor we got to see what's what's
going on with you so i go in and the
doctor is like feeling my lymph nodes
and and all of that and the doctor's
like well this looks like mono
mononucleosis and so
you need to have a lot of bed rest
and here's something i'm going to tell
you you know young feller
you're going to start feeling better
pretty soon
but
you had better
stay in bed even if you start feeling
better i don't want you to do any
exercise at all
you know i was like well can i like get
the mail or get the paper walk down the
driveway he's like you know for the
first part i don't even want you to do
that
let alone work out he like knew that i
was eager to get back to working out and
he's like you had better not lift a
single thing not weights
not boxes nothing for until i see you
next time because i'm going to give you
another test you know another blood test
and we're going to see whether or not
you know you've basically got the virus
taken care of
and if you've screwed around and not
followed my instructions it's going to
show
so what do you think i did well before i
do that
we'll tell you a few other things so i
started getting better you know within a
few days and then i'm you know i'm
looking at my weights that i've got uh
in the basement and i'm like you know i
know the doctor said i'm not supposed to
lift weights but
it really couldn't hurt that much could
it and so so i started working out again
and uh of course i did it secretly
because my mom you know would have
gotten mad at me if she if she'd known
and sure enough we go back to the doctor
i'm feeling great and the doctor you
know is like well your blood test is
pretty clear
uh you screwed around and now you're
gonna have to spend the whole summer
resting so you can get over this and i
was like
what and he's like yep no exercise for
you
maybe maybe by the end of the summer but
i want you to spend as much time as
possible
in bed
and
you can't do any sort of you know
exercise or anything like that
you can walk and get the mail but that's
about it and i was like oh this sucks
and now fortunately i was a big reader
right so i could go to the library and
get books and i did spend a lot of time
reading my mom interestingly enough
decided that since i was going to spend
the summer you know
largely in bed
that it was time to replace my bed with
a water bed and if you don't know what a
water bed is it's you know there's
there's a bed frame and then there's
like a mattress but the mattress is
actually
essentially like a big balloon filled
with water with kind of thick edges
yeah not edges up but but a shell right
and you fill it up with water and then
you can heat it
and you lay in it and it like makes
waves and stuff like that and i think
the idea back then was it was supposed
to be like supportive for your body
it was a big thing in the 70s and the
80s and so i'm stuck now you know
spending the summer windows open i can
hear all the other kids playing outside
i can walk outside and see them and hang
out with them to some degree of course
they don't want to hang out that much
because they want to go do things right
so i'm reading you know and taking it
easy and all that sort of stuff
tried of course calling lori
but by that time you know i was getting
the brush off because now she's going
out with college guys right because
she's she's moving on up i you know i
was just a fling for her and of course i
get my heart broken about that and then
move on
i also missed this really cool trip that
i was supposed to
go on with um
other other you know people in in my
grade uh where we go up to the boundary
waters
in um
you know on the on the border of uh
um
minnesota and and canada and camp out
for like a week you know portage with
canoes and cool stuff like that which i
did end up doing the next summer but uh
it had to be postponed because i i
couldn't go anywhere couldn't really do
anything
and you know it was it was a long long
grind right like i said i did get a lot
of reading done but i don't think i
actually like studied anything
extensively i didn't apply myself or
anything like that i did finish up my
school year
[Music]
because the track meet was not at the
very end i think we had like another
week of classes and then week of final
exams
so i had to do all of that stuff
from home and this is you know long
before the internet or anything like
that there's nothing online my mom had
to physically go to the school
get the homework assignments get my
books get all the stuff bring it back to
me i had to complete it in my room and
then she had to take it back to
to my high school and and hand in all
the stuff but all of that went without
any sort of
hitch and i just remember you know what
a long
frustrating summer
that was and if you know if i'd listen
to the doctors
warnings instructions
who knows maybe i would have kicked the
mono
early and uh had the rest of the summer
to do the typical things that teenagers
do in the summer which for me was you
know skateboarding
and
you know going on on camping trips uh
which often involved you know um
you know various uh misbehavior and
drinking and things like that with my my
uh
friends and
uh what else you know doing other other
uh things riding bikes taking hikes you
know spending a lot of time outside
and so you know that was all basically
precluded because i thought that i was
smarter than the doctor turns out
i wasn't
and so you know it's kind of an
interesting story beginning with um
you know a
kind of coming-of-age ritual you could
call it uh leading into
getting sick and then spending the
entire summer recovering from it and you
know i still have uh the virus in my
system i'm sure you know for a long time
anytime i would get sick my lymph nodes
would would swell up the doctor said
they'd never quite go back to normal
after after having it but i don't think
it's been you know creating any any
serious problems for me but it's you
know it's tough to tell isn't it so
that's my story about the summer that i
got motto
you